My name is Diakolola Amujo. I am a recent psychology graduate from Ireland. I am also an aspiring clinical psychologist. Dr. Marion's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, has been so helpful to me on this journey to becoming a clinical psychologist. As I plan to continue postgraduate studies in the UK, I found it extremely useful that this book provided in-depth information information on the UK declineside application process. I enjoyed reading about the experiences of
我叫Diakolola Amujo。我刚从爱尔兰心理学专业毕业。我也是一名有志成为临床心理学家的人。Marion博士的书《临床心理学家集体》在我成为临床心理学家的旅程中对我帮助很大。由于我计划在英国继续攻读研究生，我发现这本书提供了关于英国临床心理学博士申请流程的深入信息，这对我来说极其有用。我很喜欢阅读关于
both qualified and training clinical psychologists. The various narratives were my favorite part of the book, as everyone's story was different and it provided amazing insights into the clinical psychology journey. I would definitely recommend this book to anyone interested in psychology and aspires to become a clinical psychologist. Have you ever carried something that made you feel broken, exposed or unlovable? That, my friend, might well be shame. But what if it didn't have to define you? What if you could recover from it?
合格的临床心理学家和实习临床心理学家的经历。各种叙述是我最喜欢的部分，因为每个人的故事都不同，它为临床心理学之旅提供了惊人的见解。我绝对会向任何对心理学感兴趣并渴望成为临床心理学家的人推荐这本书。你是否曾经背负过让你感到破碎、暴露或不可爱的东西？我的朋友，那很可能就是羞耻感。但如果它不必定义你呢？如果你能从中恢复过来呢？
I'm Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist. And today we're going to be talking about how people heal from shame and how you can too. Hope you find it really useful and if you do, please like and subscribe for more. Hi, welcome along and thank you for being here. So in episode one, we were thinking about what shame is, where it comes from and how it can distort the way that we see ourselves. But today we're focusing on something even more powerful and that is recovery. Whether you're an aspiring psych, a mental health professional, someone supporting others,
我是Marianne博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。今天我们将讨论人们如何从羞耻感中治愈，以及你如何也能做到。希望你觉得它真的有用，如果觉得有用，请点赞并订阅以获取更多内容。嗨，欢迎收看，感谢你的到来。在第一集中，我们思考了什么是羞耻感，它从哪里来，以及它如何扭曲我们看待自己的方式。但今天我们专注于更强大的东西，那就是恢复。无论你是有抱负的心理学家、心理健康专业人士、支持他人的人，
or just someone who's carrying that shame yourself, this one is definitely for you. How do we actually recover from shame? Let's take a look at the practical and psychological strategies that help people move from stuckness to healing. Number one, name it and externalise it. Shame loves secrecy. So the first step really is as simple as naming it, acknowledging that it's there.
还是你自己正背负着那种羞耻感的人，这一集绝对适合你。我们如何真正从羞耻感中恢复？让我们看看帮助人们从停滞状态走向治愈的实用和心理策略。第一，命名它并将其外化。羞耻感喜欢秘密。所以第一步其实很简单，就是命名它，承认它的存在。
It might look like noticing, I feel ashamed. And then just starting to explore why. Once we say it out loud, we start to see shame not as something we are, but as something we've been made to feel. And that is such a powerful and important shift. Number two, understand the roots. Shame often stems from early experiences, which could include trauma, cultural or family norms, or experiences of repeated invalidation.
这可能表现为注意到：我感到羞耻。然后开始探索原因。一旦我们大声说出来，我们就开始把羞耻感看作不是我们本身，而是我们被迫感受到的东西。这是一个非常强大且重要的转变。第二，了解根源。羞耻感通常源于早期的经历，可能包括创伤、文化或家庭规范，或反复被否定的经历。
Therapies such as compassion-focused therapy, CFT, schema therapy, and I'm movement desensitization and reprocessing EMDR can really help us begin to trace those roots and make sense of where the shame began and importantly why it was never our fault. Number three, cultivate compassion. Shame says loud and clear you're not good enough. Compassion says you're human and you're doing your best. We really do need to be able to cultivate, strengthen our inner compassionate voice if we are going to be able to overcome shame. It's kind of a non-negotiable. We need to challenge that critical narrative that shame creates and often then when we're feeling brighter, speaking to ourselves more calmly and more
诸如慈悲聚焦疗法（CFT）、图式疗法和眼动脱敏再加工（EMDR）等疗法，真的可以帮助我们开始追溯这些根源，弄清楚羞耻感从何而来，更重要的是，为什么这从来都不是我们的错。第三，培养慈悲心。羞耻感清楚地告诉你：你不够好。慈悲心则说：你是人类，你正在尽力而为。如果我们想要克服羞耻感，我们确实需要能够培养和加强我们内在的慈悲声音。这是一种不可妥协的要求。我们需要挑战羞耻感所创造的批判性叙述，通常当我们感觉更好、更冷静地对自己说话时，
kindly, we will often then be able to receive that same level of positive validation from others too. So if you have perhaps applied for a job and you didn't get it, a compassionate reframe of that might look like, well, I didn't get it this time, but I know that that doesn't mean I'm not worthy of it in future. And if you're noticing a real slump in your energy levels, you know, we can honour and respect what we've been up to in the day, the week, the month, the year, and kind of reframe that not as being lazy, but while I'm allowed to be tired and I'm still good enough, when I'm tired and I can allow myself to restore my energy levels and come out the other side when I'm ready. Number four, we're going to reclaim the narrative. Once we stop treating shame
更友善地对待自己，我们通常也能从他人那里获得同样程度的积极认可。所以，如果你可能申请了一份工作但没有得到，一个慈悲的重新框架可能是：好吧，这次我没得到，但我知道这并不意味着我未来不配得到它。如果你注意到自己的能量水平大幅下降，你知道，我们可以尊重和认可我们在这一天、这一周、这一月、这一年所做的事情，并将其重新框架，不是因为懒惰，而是因为我允许自己疲惫，即使疲惫我也依然足够好，我可以允许自己恢复能量水平，并在准备好时重新出发。第四，我们要夺回叙事权。一旦我们停止对待羞耻感
like it's a hundred percent bona fide truth, we can then start to rewrite the story. From I'm broken to I'm healing, from I'm weak to I've survived more than people know. This is where our identity begins to shift and that power, that position in the driving seat, so to speak, really starts to return to you. Let's check back in with Amina, who we met in the first episode. She was really struggling with her position in her career. She was weighed down by this shame and kind of by what she learned was the impact of cultural expectations upon her. There was a very deep fear of disappointing others and this was showing up for her as shame and this was kind of linked to her job but of course when she began to go deeper on this with a therapist she realized that this was
就像它是百分之百的真理一样，我们就可以开始重写故事。从“我破碎了”到“我正在治愈”，从“我很软弱”到“我经历的比人们知道的更多”。这就是我们的身份开始转变的地方，那种力量，那种坐在驾驶座上的位置，可以说，真的开始回归到你手中。让我们回到我们在第一集中遇到的Amina。她真的在职业生涯的位置上挣扎。她被这种羞耻感压得喘不过气来，某种程度上是因为她所了解到的文化期望对她的影响。有一种非常深层的恐惧是让别人失望，这表现为她的羞耻感，这与她的工作有关，但当然，当她开始与治疗师深入探讨这个问题时，她意识到这
mapping out in all areas of her life too not just her career so recovery did start when she started working with a therapist who normalized her feelings and helped her explore her values those which were her own and felt authentic to who she is and who she wants to be in future. She began to practice self-compassion. She gently challenged those inherited beliefs and she found a sense of community with others who'd faced similar struggles in the past too. This then validated everything she felt and made her realise that it wasn't her as a bad person.
也映射到了她生活的各个领域，不仅仅是她的职业。所以，当她开始与一位治疗师合作时，恢复就开始了。治疗师使她的感受正常化，并帮助她探索自己的价值观，那些属于她自己并对她未来想成为的人感到真实的价值观。她开始练习自我慈悲。她温和地挑战了那些继承的信念，并与过去也面临过类似挣扎的其他人找到了社区感。这验证了她所感受到的一切，并让她意识到她并不是一个坏人。
It was just the treatment that she'd experienced was far from what she'd deserved all along. Bit by bit, she started to believe, I'm not selfish, I'm allowed to want more. This helped her to be able to apply herself in work situations to get the goals that she was striving for. It also allowed herself the time to get there when she was ready, rather than measuring herself against someone else's yardstick. Now Amina has come to a place where she's still able to honour her culture, her religion, her heritage, but she no longer sacrifices her. herself in the process. She has found balance and she describes herself as learning to be authentically a meaner. Of course I've made amina up. She's not a real person, but so many of her struggles might feel so relatable because this is what shame does to us. What about James?
这只是她所经历的待遇远非她一直以来应得的。一点一点地，她开始相信：我并不自私，我有权想要更多。这帮助她在工作场合能够投入，以实现她所追求的目标。这也让她在准备好时有时间去实现目标，而不是用别人的标准来衡量自己。现在Amina已经到了一个能够尊重她的文化、宗教和传统的地方，但她不再在这个过程中牺牲自己。她找到了平衡，她形容自己正在学习成为真实的Amina。当然，Amina是我编造的。她不是一个真实的人，但她的许多挣扎可能会让人感到非常共鸣，因为这就是羞耻感对我们所做的。那James呢？
When we met him in the first episode, he was really struggling with a tidal wave of shame after finding out that his partner had cheated on him. He was blaming himself, he had withdrawn from others, and he was questioning his own judgment, his own masculinity, and whether he would ever be good enough to be with anyone again in future. Healing began for James when he started working with a therapist and named what had happened, not just the betrayal, but the shame he was experiencing which was attached to it. He learned that being cheated on doesn't mean that he's unlovable. someone else made a choice and that you got hurt in the process. Over time, he began to rebuild trust in himself.
当我们在第一集中见到他时，他在发现伴侣欺骗他后，正处于羞耻感的浪潮中挣扎。他在责备自己，他退出了社交，他在质疑自己的判断力、自己的男子气概，以及未来是否还能足够好去和任何人在一起。James的治愈始于他开始与治疗师合作，并命名了所发生的事情，不仅仅是背叛，还有他所经历的与此相关的羞耻感。他了解到被欺骗并不意味着他不可爱。别人做出了选择，而你在过程中受到了伤害。随着时间的推移，他开始重建对自己的信任。
He even began dating, not from a place of fear or of getting over his partner, but with curiosity and respect for himself. Of course, like any of us, he still has moments of doubt, but he stopped believing the story that shame was making him believe about himself. He's reclaimed that narrative. He's reclaimed his position in the driving seat. Now, he says about that experience, well, it doesn't define me.
他甚至开始约会，不是出于恐惧或为了忘记伴侣，而是带着好奇心和对自己的尊重。当然，像我们任何人一样，他仍然会有怀疑的时刻，但他停止相信羞耻感让他相信的关于他自己的故事。他夺回了叙事权。他夺回了坐在驾驶座上的位置。现在，他说起那段经历时说：好吧，它并没有定义我。
It's just taught me what I want to do differently in future. So shame is incredibly powerful. It has the ability to make us very small and very stuck, but it is not permanent. It can be a transition. state. And it's kind of anti-venom, so to speak, is most definitely curiosity, compassion and community. That's when it really loses its grip. If you're experiencing shame, you don't have to carry it forever. If you need advice or support, please check out the details on
它只是教会了我未来想做些什么不同的事情。所以羞耻感是非常强大的。它有能力让我们变得非常渺小和停滞，但它不是永久的。它可能是一种过渡状态。可以说，它的解毒剂绝对是好奇心、慈悲心和社区。那时它才会真正失去控制力。如果你正在经历羞耻感，你不必永远背负它。如果你需要建议或支持，请查看
screen or in the show notes. You might also like to know that I do still offer one-to-one therapy and have some limited availability at times too so if you would like me to be your therapist please do get in touch if you're an aspiring psychologist i also run the aspiring psychologist membership and if you're ready for something a little bit more intensive the ready to rise program come and grab your free psychology success guide on my website www. Aspiring-psychologist.com.com. If you haven't already watched episode one on shame, please do so, it will come up on the screen very shortly.
屏幕上或节目说明中的详细信息。你可能还想知道，我确实仍然提供一对一的治疗，有时也有有限的空档，所以如果你想让我成为你的治疗师，请务必联系我。如果你是有抱负的心理学家，我也经营着“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”，如果你准备好进行更深入的学习，可以参加“准备崛起”项目，并在我的网站www.Aspiring-psychologist.com上获取你的免费心理学成功指南。如果你还没有观看关于羞耻感的第一集，请观看，它很快就会出现在屏幕上。
Thank you so much for being part of my world. If you've liked this content, please like and subscribe for more. Please drop me a comment to let me know what you found helpful and what content you would find helpful in future too. If you're listening on Spotify, you can also drop me a question or answer or comment there too. looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast that's your side you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist podcast Hi, I'm Max and a work as an assistant psychologist in the Learning Disability Service in West Yorkshire.
非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。如果你喜欢这个内容，请点赞并订阅以获取更多。请给我留言，让我知道你觉得什么有帮助，以及未来你觉得什么内容会有帮助。如果你在Spotify上收听，你也可以在那里给我提问、回答或评论。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南，有这个播客在身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是“有抱负的心理学家播客”。嗨，我是Max，我在西约克郡的学习障碍服务中心担任助理心理学家。
Like most people working in psychology, I'm slowly but surely working myself up to that seemingly impossible goal of getting onto the clinical doctorate. With that angle in mind, I thought I'd have a look at what's out there and see what books might be helpful for this. I came across Marianne's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, and decided that this would be a great for me to help me on my journey. I found Marion's book really informative, most insightful. I especially liked how the stories reassured me that you don't need to be academically perfect to become a psychologist, and that as long as you have good interpersonal skills, such
像大多数从事心理学工作的人一样，我正在缓慢但肯定地朝着那个看似不可能的目标努力，即进入临床博士课程。考虑到这一点，我想看看外面有什么，看看哪些书可能对我有帮助。我偶然发现了Marianne的书《临床心理学家集体》，并决定这对我的旅程将是一个巨大的帮助。我发现Marion的书非常丰富，非常有见地。我特别喜欢这些故事如何向我保证，你不需要在学术上完美才能成为心理学家，只要你有良好的人际交往能力，例如
as compassion and empathy, you will get there. I would highly recommend this book to all aspiring psychologists, and also those who want to know a bit more about the world of clinical psychology and made me want to work in that field one day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如慈悲和同理心，你就会成功。我会强烈向所有有抱负的心理学家推荐这本书，也向那些想多了解临床心理学世界的人推荐，它让我有一天想在那个领域工作。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。